the democrats are struggling here their
agenda is falling apart
they are not able to push forward any
elements of their agenda and they are
facing down some real problems right
that problem on the border it ain't
going away
how bad is the problem on the border
it's so bad that it's hilarious to kamal
harris there's a basic rule for kamala
harris
the funniest things in life are hard
questions you can't answer they're
they're so funny like i i desperately
want to play poker with kamala harris
like
she has the worst poker face in the
entire world the minute
that she has asked a remotely difficult
question she starts
falling like a crazy person it's wild
she should be handing people cards like
like joaquin phoenix and joker that says
i'm sorry i have a condition like
i don't know where it's coming from but
it's so weird
she's so bad at this joe biden must
remain alive
for the democrats to have any shot at
2024 because if kamala harris is their
candidate she is not winning a national
election there's just
no way the latest example so she's
appearing with lester holt
the border crisis continues to be a
crisis and he asks her
about the border crisis this is one of
the worst clips of any politician i have
ever seen in my life particularly a
politician who's supposed to be so
professional
and so poised and so incredible at this
here's kamala harris being an utterly
crazy incoherent person
just quickly put a button okay do you
have any plans
to visit the border at some point you
know
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole
this whole this whole thing about the
border we've been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
i'm not discounting the importance of
the border well i mentioned it because
i know republicans have certainly come
at you on this but democratic
congressman cuellar
has a border district has said to the
you and the president come you
can't see this listen i care about
what's happening at the border
she's shaking her head while she talks
about how much she cares which is always
a great indicator
also nothing is quite as hilarious
as being asked a question you have no
answer for i mean she always looks like
she's right on the verge
of laughing like like really like the
joker she breaks into that crazy
grin and it's it's so wild man it's so
crazy
and also her answer he says you haven't
been down to the border and she's like i
haven't been to europe either
i are we having a migration crisis from
europe right now are there like
several tens of thousands of children
who are being held in cages
in some sort of internment camp that i
didn't know about from europe also do we
have a border with europe at last i
checked i mean i may not be a geographic
expert but there's like a giant ocean
between us
and europe and there is nothing
between us and mexico other than some
wall that you guys want to tear down
so um and and some river that people can
cross so i'm just wondering like
what now she's so bad at this
she's so terrible at this
i swear if if biden if biden slips going
down those stairs
to air force one the democrat era of
dominance is over immediately because
that lady is not capable
of leading a successful democratic party
combining a radical agenda
with a non-moderate half senile face
like joe biden combine that radical
agenda
with kamala harris who is more
intellectually with it than joe biden is
at this point but also completely unable
to hide
what appears to be a movie villain laugh
lurking beneath the facade
it's what i've told my kids many many
times i've told them if you want to be
happy in life if you want to enjoy life
become a movie villain because if you
ever watch movies it's always the movie
villain who's having a great time right
i mean like the emperor in return of the
jedi he's constantly laughing right
likes a ball
he's just really enjoying jafar in in
aladdin
right villains have the best time i've
never seen a politician
laugh like kamala harris laughs unless
it's in a movie and there's
music that is coming up that it like
rising villainous music from beneath
it's like
it's so crazy man she is so bad at this
i love the fact that the democrats
picked her specifically on the basis of
her race and on the basis of her sex
and now they are stuck with her they
cannot replace her you understand
because if they replace her then they
have replaced a black woman
so if joe biden were to fall down on air
force one
and if the life alert weren't to work
god forbid
and she would become president of the
united states or if joe biden were to
retire and she were to run in 2024
democrats are screwed
they have a serious kamala harris
problem because they can't supplant her
with anybody else
because that would be to reverse the
cause of equity you can't replace a
black woman with somebody else
she's like right at the top of that
intersectional hierarchy so unless they
can come up
with like a a pansexual half native
american
half black transgender person
unless they can come up with that to
replace kamala harris on the ticket they
are screwed identity politics has locked
them
in and this is what they are stuck with
it's kamala harris
good luck to you guys you made this bed
now you are going to have to lie in the
bed of identity politics by making an
identity politics politician your vp
without any regard to whether she is
even good at this
[Music]
they have a serious problem whereas
kamala harris might put it
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video